let me congratulate all Member States
with the newly agreed measures to
straighten the administrative
cooperation and fight against fraud in
the area of v80 second I would turn to
the agreement to make permanent 15%
minimum standard to the v80 rate
currently in place this decision will
have protect fair competition and trade
among our member states especially in
cross border regions and thus safeguard
jobs and growth in the EU today we turn
to the risk sharing part of the banking
Union the European Deposit Insurance
Scheme by taking stock of the progress
made technical level welcomes
endorsement by ministers of country
specific recommendations now what
matters is implementation authors
recommendations for example as regards
last year now less than half of all
recommendations had at least some
progress in implementation clearly we
can do better
ministers also confirmed our decisions
under the stability and growth pact they
endorsed our proposal to obligate the
excessive deficit procedure for France
which leaves only one member state under
the corrective our most stability and
respect down from 24 countries in 2011
ministers also confirms of you that in
case of Romania and Hungary there is a
case for significant deviation
procedures so we adopted the adjustment
pass for both countries to correct the
deviation